what do you make of that well ebi my
first question would be is it true or is
it just gonna be on his top 10 tonight I
get the late April will see great
stories I told today and you've got you
um well you know he has to sit down at
some time but he doesn't have to do it
now true um would it be a big loss baby
answer is it get new blood he makes an
enormous amount of money people have no
idea how much David makes from that show
it's just an enormous amount and maybe
that's not an issue with him anymore and
it's he's such a figure in the industry
les Moonves is also very sharp so he'll
have his hands full picking a winner out
of that NBC's got two very talented
people there hmm in Seth Meyers and
Jimmy Fallon I assume their contracts
don't don't allow you to go across the
street to do that probably not and I'm
guessing the other people all have
contracts too so it's not going to be
you know I'm not gonna be so simple to
pick a place I'm gonna float a crazy
idea right yeah what about a woman
running a late night show any Poehler
Tina Fey there's not there's nothing
wrong with that idea though I'm breaking
and and the good news is that both of
them I believe would be free to do that
they're not under that kind of a
contractual limitation as people doing
that kind of a show so Tina is extremely
big time media person writer producer
performer right I don't know that she
want that grind i just made to no good
point when when when TV networks gonna
undergo this kind of big shift in talent
what does it do for them in the
short-term versus long-term well you
know he is he has been there Nate late
night now for 20 some odd years you'd
like to think somebody goes into that
it's going to be a an imagery for the
network for a long long time so it does
have real value it has value beyond its
its its own particular income
and if if they're good like Jay was and
like Carson wasn't and certainly like
the master right now you can you can you
can have him there for a long time or
have her there for a long time that not
very many programs you can do that with
no a good point it's really about that
talent and you can stream it now you can
do a lot of things with it there's a lot
of things can be done with those shows
look at Lorne Michaels has done with SNL